Котиться «лісопет», «ровер», «біціглі», «велосипед».
Шкварчить «сковорідка», «пательня», «рондель», «чара».
Парує смачна «бульба», «мандебурка», «картопля», «біб».
Така різна і водночас така українська мова.
Як вона сформувалася?
Чому, попри всі заборони, не зникла, а збагатилася?
Як протистояла русифікації та
чому буквально розквітла за ранніх «совітів»?
А те, як говорить діаспора, а діалекти?
А всі ці нові «чілити» і «чекінитись» —
це, взагалі, цейво, українська?
У найближчі 15 хвилин ми будемо
говорити тільки про українську мову
та розставимо крапки не тільки над літерою «Ї».
Українська, як і решта слов’янських мов,
походить із праслов’янської.
Праслов’янська мовна єдність — гіпотетична.
Адже розпалася ще до появи
слов’янської писемності.
А що ж протоукраїнська мова?
Її визначальні риси сформувалися
протягом VI – XI століть.
Наприклад, певні закінчення у певних відмінках іменників.
Або кличний відмінок іменників.
Чи закінчення «-мо» у дієсловах.
Ці риси українська успадкувала від праслов’янської.
Водночас з’явилися риси,
притаманні лише українській.
Точніше, протоукраїнській мові.
Скажімо, звук «г», на противагу
праслов’янському «ґ».
Потім «ґ» ще повернеться.
Чи заміна «е» на «о» після певних звуків.
Кінець XI — середина XII століття — це початок
існування української мови як системи,
що своїми рисами вже відрізнялася
від систем інших мов.
Втім, ми достеменно не знаємо,
як говорили українці в XI столітті.
Подкастів тоді ще не було.
Зате знаємо, як вони писали.
Хоч і фейсбуку ще не було.
Писемна мова Київської Русі
існувала у двох різновидах.
Церковнослов’янська мова,
яка обслуговувала потреби церкви,
але поступово, віки за віками,
вбирала у себе риси живої мови.
І давньоруська, вона ж
давньоукраїнська, вона ж давньокиївська.
Ще одна літературна мова Русі.
Вона виконувала державні та світські культурні функції.
Нею написані «Руська правда», «Повість минулих літ»,
«Повчання Володимира Мономаха», «Слово о полку Ігоревім».
Тут ми вже бачимо м’яке «ць»,
заміну [л]  в окремих формах на український звук [ў],
який на письмі позначали літерою «ве».
Закінчення «-ть» у дієсловах: «ходить».
А ще бачимо багато знайомих
нам нині українських слів.
Винахід книгодрукування не перешкодив проникненню
в тексти елементів живої української мови.
Українські книжники розуміли
важливість і літературних, і народної мов.
Так, Лаврентій Зизаній уклав «Лексис».
Це словник церковнослов’янської мови
з поясненням слів простою українською,
в якій були й елементи живої народної мови.
А Мелетій Смотрицький запровадив літеру «ґ»,
адже цей звук вимовляли у багатьох словах
Як і будь-яка мова, українська
не формувалась у вакуумі.
Коли Русь хрестилась,
її мова збагатилась грецизмами.
Слов'янську азбуку, як відомо,
було створено на основі грецького письма.
А десятки і сотні грецизмів попливли
в церковне життя й документи.
Тісні контакти зі степом приносили тюркські слова.
За тісних контактів із Кримським
ханством цей процес тільки посилиться.
Натомість великі міста набирались латини,
через появу єзуїтських колегіумів
та інших навчальних закладів.
В українській мові багато запозичень і з їдишу.
До речі, цей обмін був двосторонній.
Ціла Європа вимовляє «боршт»,
бо в їдиші це слово читається саме так.
Упродовж своєї історії українська
запозичувала слова з різних мов.
Із польської, німецької, угорської, румунської.
Так розвивається кожна мова!
І, поки українська позичала собі лексику в сусідів,
українські слова теж потрапляли в інші мови.
Найперше ми експортували екзотизми,
тобто слова, що передають суто українські реалії.
Але важить не тільки екзотика.
Суттєву роль відіграє і сусідство.
Українізми побутують у польській мові.
І в сусідній, хоч і не спорідненій, угорській.
У румунській ці впливи ще помітніші.
Українізувалась і російська.
Українська мова вдосконалювалася,
ставала гнучкішою, точнішою, співучішою.
Мовою і простих людей, і непростих текстів.
Але такі тенденції подобалися не всім.
На початку XVIII століття Україна
була окупована Російською імперією.
Цар Петро І видав указ про заборону друкувати в Україні
книжки церковнослов’янською мовою української редакції.
[російською] Щоб не було
жодної різниці та відмінності між мовами.
За 9 років Петро ІІ, а був і такий, наказав переписати
з української на російську всі державні документи.
А 1763-го Катерина ІІ заборонила використовувати книжну
українську мову в Києво-Могилянській академії.
Але українська мова жила й розвивалася.
Наприкінці XVIII століття
стара українська літературна мова,
останнім відомим представником якої був
Григорій Сковорода, вийшла з ужитку.
Та чимало її елементів усе ж перейшли
у нову українську літературну мову,
що постала на народній основі.
Перші твори цією мовою написав Котляревський.
А найвідоміші — Шевченко.
«Енеїда» вийшла в кінці XVIII століття в Петербурзі.
«Кобзар» там само через 42 роки.
Обидві книжки стають бестселерами і дають
переконливу відповідь на питання про те,
чи можна народною українською мовою не лише
жартувати й купувати на базарі цибулю,
а й писати серйозні, епічні
та навіть пророчі тексти.
Можна.
До речі, прихід розмовної мови
в мову літературну,
а відтак і домінування її, –
відбувався і в інших країнах.
На початку XIV століття Данте Аліг’єрі написав
«Божественну комедію» розмовною мовою регіону Тоскана.
І цей діалект завдяки твору став
основою літературної італійської.
А в Османській імперії,
хоч і писали османською мовою,
та більшість послуговувалася
так званою «грубою турецькою».
Вона й лягла в основу сучасної
турецької літературної мови.
Але що міцніше ставала
на ноги українська мова,
то жорстокіший тиск чинила
на неї Російська імперія.
Тільки у другій половині
XIX століття й на початку XX,
вийшло майже 500 цензурних указів
щодо української мови.
Найпомітніший з них – Валуєвський циркуляр.
Він забороняв друк книжок
українською, бо, мовляв,
[російською] «Ніякої малоросійської
мови не було, немає і бути не може».
А ще Емський указ, який забороняв
використання мови у школі, церкві, газетах,
журналах, науці, офіційно-діловій сфері,
в публічних виступах, у театрі.
Чого тільки не забороняли —
і хрещення українськими іменами,
і переклад російських книжок українською,
і навіть український текст під нотами.
Існував би тоді український YouTube,
його б теж заборонили.
Але, на щастя, залишалися ще
не підвладні Росії інші українські регіони.
Як-от Галичина, Закарпаття,
Буковина, Пряшівщина.
Тож коли на «Великій Україні»
ввели в дію Емський указ,
українське книговидання
перемістилося на Галичину.
Там були свої особливі слова,
що тепер почали наповнювати літературну мову.
Тож, на початок XX століття, мова Котляревського і Шевченка
виявилася суттєво поповнена словами із західних теренів.
XX століття для української мови виявилося
не менш бурхливим та драматичним.
Перша світова війна та революція
1917 року стали потужним поштовхом
для розвитку національно-визвольного
руху на українських землях.
Створювалися українські органи влади,
політичні партії, відроджувалася культура.
В Українській Народній Республіці
та Українській Державі гетьмана Скоропадського
українська стала мовою законодавства,
адміністрації, війська, частково освіти.
Масово відкривалися українські школи,
видавництва, бібліотеки.
Але сплеск українізації жорстоко
перервали більшовики.
У перші роки «совітів» влада ледве
толерувала українську мову.
Наприклад, за першого більшовицького
захоплення Києва людей,
що говорили літературною українською,
вважали ворогами й часом навіть розстрілювали.
Але вже за кілька років,
як це не дивно, почалася українізація.
Загалом по Радянському Союзу
це звалось коренізацією.
Владу на місцях мали наповнити
корінні мешканці.
В Україні цими мешканцями були
переважно українськомовні селяни.
Тож міста стрімко українізувалися.
У школах та вишах запроваджували українську мову.
Більшість книжок, газет та журналів
виходила українською.
Українізувалися також театр і кіно.
Ба більше!
Українізація відбувалася і на тих землях,
які не входили в УСРР, але етнічно були українськими
Тож українською говорила і
писала не тільки Кубань, але й Курщина,
Воронежчина та навіть Зелений Клин
на Далекому Сході.
Так, у ті роки нашу мову можна було почути навіть
на узбережжі Японського моря.
Але найважливіше, що в цей час
мова не тільки поширювалась.
Вона розвивалася.
Унормовано та офіційно
затверджено український правопис,
що набув статусу обов’язкового.
Сьогодні ми знаємо цей правопис
як «харківський», або «скрипниківку».
Розвивалася термінологія.
Вийшли три томи
«Російсько-українського словника»
за редакцією Агатангела Кримського
та Сергія Єфремова
Словник давав багатющий матеріал
із питомої української лексики!
Але четвертий, завершальний том видати не встигли.
На початку 1930 стало ясно:
українізація була засобом, а не метою.
Єдине, для чого більшовикам
була потрібна коренізація, — це лояльність
населення нових республік
та зміцнення власних позицій.
1932 року цю політику стали згортати.
Почалися репресії.
Тоді ув’язнили чимало мовознавців, письменників,
драматургів, режисерів, науковців.
«Їхня українізація — це спосіб виявити всіх нас, українців,
а тоді знищити разом, щоб і духу не було…».
Каже дядько Тарас, герой драми
Миколи Куліша «Мина Мазайло».
Існуючі словники та правопис
оголосили буржуазно-націоналістичними.
Почалося укладання нових словників,
які «усували бар’єри між українською та російською мовами».
Радянська влада стала втручатися
у внутрішні механізми мови.
Були заборонені окремі слова, синтаксичні конструкції,
граматичні форми.
Накидали натомість ті, що ближчі
до російських, або й геть скальковані.
І навіть літеру «ґ» з української абетки
вилучили як «націоналістичну».
Майже всі заклади освіти були зросійщені.
Звісно, така політика викликала спротив.
Він проявлявся у різних формах –
від поміркованих до радикальних.
Ось лише кілька яскравих прикладів.
Ще за Сталіна Максим Рильський
у «Літературній газеті» писав:
«Система декретування, заборон і
обмежень, система адміністрування
ніяк не може бути корисна
для розвитку мовної культури».
Борис Антоненко-Давидович у 1960 — 1970
поставив питання про повернення літери «ґ».
Іван Світличний критикував російсько-український
словник 1978 року за зросійщення української.
А потім у концтаборі працював
над словником синонімів.
Іван Дзюба 1965 року написав книжку
«Інтернаціоналізм чи русифікація?»
1978 року акт самоспалення на знак
протесту проти русифікації вчинив Олекса Гірник.
Незалежність України, здобута в 1991 році,
на жаль, не дорівнювала українізації.
Так, українська мова оголошена єдиною державною.
Так, кількість шкіл з українською мовою навчання зростає.
Кількість годин на її вивчення — теж.
Так, вступні кампанії у вишах
провадять державною мовою
Іспит з української став обов’язковим.
Засновуються нові видавництва.
Виходять чудові оригінальні й перекладні книжки.
Та, на жаль, по трьох століттях
зросійщення діяла інерція.
З Росії безперешкодно постачають книжки.
Через великий тираж вони дешевші за українські.
У музиці — хоч і з’явилися цікаві
виконавці, що співали українською,
більш престижною мовою
шоу-бізнесу все одно була російська.
У пресі, на телебаченні, в кіно домінувала російська.
Деякі зрушення були після Помаранчевої революції.
Наприклад, встановлено квоти на мовлення й музику
українською в ефірі теле- і радіостанцій.
Всі іноземні фільми мали дублюватись
або субтитруватись українською.
Попри страшилки російських дистриб'юторів,
що це відштовхне глядачів,
люди по всій країні і далі ходили в кінотеатри.
Та з приходом проросійського президента Віктора Януковича
попередні здобутки намагаються скасувати.
Зі скандалом прийнято так званий
«Закон Колесніченка-Ківалова»,
який ще більше розширював поле
для російської мови.
Люди не згодні.
Починається «Мовний Майдан».
Ми знаємо, чим закінчилось це президентство.
Після перемоги «Революції Гідності»
почалася нова українізація.
Закон «Про освіту» посилив роль
української мови на всіх рівнях навчання.
При цьому представники корінних
народів і національних меншин
мають право навчатись у школах
і рідною для них мовою.
Засновано культурні інституції.
Український культурний фонд,
Український інститут книги, Український інститут.
Виходять українські фільми українською мовою.
Багато з них стають касовими.
2019 року нарешті прийнято закон,
який розширює сферу вживання державної мови.
Зокрема в обслуговуванні,
освіті, телерадіомовленні.
Питаєте, чи змінилася в ці роки сама мова?
Звісно!
Мова постійно змінюється.
Найшвидше змінюється молодіжний сленг.
20 років тому:
«— Ти вкурив?»
«— Ти з мене виганяєшся?»
Сьогодні:
«— Ти мене тролиш?
— Мені не зайшло.»
З’являються нові слова,
щоб називати нові явища.
Так, чимало з них — англіцизми,
як у більшості сучасних мов.
Багато англіцизмів успішно українізуються.
Втім, час від часу ми не лінуємось
творити й нові питомі слова.
Вертаються і старі забуті.
І якщо фемінітиви в нас були й раніше,
і у словнику Кримського та Єфремова їх пребагато,
то тепер вони ринули великою хвилею!
Їх вживають і пишуть, і вони
закріплені в новому правописі
А ще, не забудьмо:
українська мова — це і її діалекти.
Науковці поділяють українську мову на три наріччя.
Північне, або поліське,
південно-західне та південно-східне.
У трьох наріччях — 15 говорів.
У межах говорів — безліч говірок.
Бо кожне село має свою говірку,
а кожне місто — своє койне.
Ну а кожна людина має власний ідіолект.
А ще ж є діаспора,
бо «нашого цвіту – по всьому світу».
Українці у різні роки та віки везли
з собою в еміграцію українську мову,
характерну для їхнього часу.
Там вона законсервувалась.
Хоча трохи набралася й нових запозичень.
А тут, в Україні, мова змінилася в інший бік.
Радянізація, русифікація, просто нові
реалії, просто слова з інших діалектів.
Тому нам здається,
що діаспора говорить кумедно.
А діаспорі здається,
що ми всуціль русифіковані.
А ще ж є суржик!
«Кровозмісне дитя двомовності», який,
з одного боку, лишається
мовою неосвічених верств.
А з іншого — освічені використовують його задля гри.
Часом люди слова — письменники, редактори,
перекладачі — суржиком створюють «коло довіри»,
атмосферу домашності й затишку.
Сьогодні дедалі більше громадян обирають українську.
Хай навіть не як мову своїх батьків і дідів,
бо родинні ситуації могли бути різні.
А як мову своїх дітей.
Бо Україна, що розмовляє українською, —
це Україна, захищена своєю єдністю.